by joining us now is Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell is with us and
his memoir by the way is entitled the
long game it includes a new foreword by
President Trump and it's now out in
paperback center good to see you welcome
back to the program it's been a while I
want to find out about the new forward I
think most people don't fully understand
let's assume for a minute that the house
goes forward with this impeachment and
it's over to the Senate walk us through
how this process works and the options
available and what you what you see
happening and how you see this going
down first as you've pointed out to your
viewers frequently the Democrats have
been wanting to do this for three years
the first headline in the Washington
Post and before the president was
inaugurated was they were going to
impeach him well they finally got around
to it and we assume we're going to see
two articles of impeachment both of them
pretty weak stuff coming over to us and
your question is what happens then under
the rules of impeachment the Senate then
turns to it has no option but to turn to
it and it's the sole business until we
finish how we can impact that really is
just with 51 votes the Chief Justice is
in the chair I don't expect the Chief
Justice to try to tilt the playing field
either way we'll listen to the opening
arguments by the house prosecutors it
will listen to the president's lawyers
respond and then we'll have to make a
decision about the way forward and
everything I do
during this I'm coordinating with white
House Counsel there will be no
difference between the president's
position and our position as to how to
handle this to the extent that we can we
don't have the kind of ball control on
this that a typical issue for example
comes over for the house if if I don't
like it we don't take it up we have no
choice but to take it up but we'll be
working through this process hopefully
in a fairly short period of time in
total coordination with the White House
counsel's
office and the people who are
representing the president in the will
of the Senate so I've got to believe
that the federal rules for the admission
of evidence would apply here with the
Chief Justice in charge and that would
mean there would be no hearsay evidence
be allowed and that would probably mean
well you might have one or two opinion
people in fact or experts but when we
watched this process unfold in the house
especially in the ship show everyone was
hearsay or an opinion witnessed the one
fact witness said oh the president said
he was nothing no quid pro quo that was
the only fact witness that I saw
so that would be ambassador Sandlin
would that be in your view how the
Federal Rules of Evidence would apply
here
well exactly how we go forward I'm gonna
coordinate with the president's lawyers
so there won't be any difference between
us on how to do this you raise the issue
of what if you have witnesses the
president's counsel may or may not
decide they want to have witnesses the
case is so darn weak coming over from
the house we all know how it's going to
end there's no chance the president's
going to be removed from office my hope
is that there won't be a single
Republican who votes for either of these
articles of impeachment and Shawn it
wouldn't surprise me if we got one or
two Democrats it looks to me over in the
house the Republicans seem to be solid
and the Democrats seem to be divided
well I think you rightly point out this
is very weak I mean we'll look for
example the the obstruction issue so
here the president like every other past
president has exerted an executive
privilege okay they don't like it when
there is a dispute between the
legislative branch and the executive
branch well that would be the role of
the judicial ran branch which is to
resolve the disputes between the other
two branches of government but
apparently they're in such a rush to do
this that they didn't want to give the
courts any time or perhaps even worse
they feared what the courts would decide
yeah well this is a thoroughly political
exercise it's not like a courtroom
experience it's a political exercise
they've been trying to do this for three
years they finally screwed up there
to do it it looks to me like it may be
backfiring on them particularly in swing
districts that the speaker's party
managed to win in order to get to the
majority most of the nervousness I see
on this issue with the politicians since
it's a political process is on the
Democratic side so you will allow it
let's assume it comes over to the Senate
you're obligated to take it up I think
everybody understands that there are the
whoever the house chooses to present
their case they will present their case
over a long period of time that takes
there is some dispute and actually I
could probably be persuaded on either
side which for me is a rare thing
senator and and that would be okay a lot
of people would like to bring up bring
in Adam Schiff hunter Biden Joe Biden I
think I'm more inclined to agree with
Senator Graham on this it's tempting and
I do believe that that all of those
things must be looked into there are a
lot of real questions here but I don't
know if that would be the appropriate
forum once you would have the the 51
votes at that point to end this which
again very weak case I think it would be
smart to do so where would your
inclination be yeah again I'm gonna take
my cues from the from the president's
lawyers but yes if you know you have the
votes you've listened to the arguments
on both sides and believe the case is so
slim so weak is that you have the votes
to end it
that might be what the president's
lawyers would prefer and you can
certainly make a case for making it
shorter rather than longer since it's
such a weak case okay would are you
confident so we talked about for example
the obstruction charge and the other one
will be the abuse of power charge you've
read the phone call you've watched I'm
sure a lot of the coverage that has
taken place in the house do you see any
evidence of any wrongdoing whatsoever on
the president's part as you read that
transcript I read it I read it over and
over again I certainly don't see what we
hear Joe Biden bragging about you're not
getting a billion taxpayer dollars
unless you fire the prosecutor he knew
was investigating his son
with zero experience making millions
that didn't happen well this is this is
a really weak case and that's why I
think you're going to see bipartisan
opposition to the articles over the
house how long do you think it and we'll
move on from here how long would you
imagine after the house presents its
case and you that will happen in full
well look if they do it this next week
Sean know we will be able to consent to
go home for Christmas so we would turn
to it right around the 1st of the year
and we would stay on it until we finish
and my hope is that it will be a shorter
process rather than along the lengthy
process so you have your book yeah and
look
Donald Trump is a lot of things and I
probably have known him maybe longer
than you well over 20-some odd years
he's disrupter he's an iconoclast he is
a fighter he's also gotten a lot of good
things done for the country he kept a
lot of promises you with your help on
judges tax cuts certainly he's got the
money for the wall ending burdensome
regulation better trade deals Baghdad
he's dead the Caliphate defeated what
have you learned over this time with the
president now almost three years that
maybe he didn't know well let me tell
you what this book is about this book is
about the most long lasting contribution
to Donald Trump and Senate Republicans
have made for the country and that is
putting young men and women who are
strict constructionists who believe the
job the judge is to follow the law on
the courts we did our 50th Circuit Court
judge just yesterday Sean to put that in
perspective brought Barack Obama did 55
Circuit Judges in eight years we've done
50 in three years and we have at least a
year left for sure we're going to do
more one-fourth of the circuit judges
remember most cases don't make it to the
Supreme Court most complex litigation
never makes it belong beyond the circuit
courts this has been the most
long-lasting important contribution the
president could make well into the
future far beyond his tenure in office
so we'll have a Jew
more inclined not to make it up on the
fly you know President Obama said he
wanted to appoint judges who had empathy
well you know that makes great sense if
you're the litigant before the judge for
whom the judge has empathy not so good
if you aren't let's talk about the
issues come up let's say somebody were
to retire at the end of this year
leading into the summer you have been
very clear if the president appointed
somebody you would follow through on
that nomination absolutely we definitely
do that and this paper back that we were
just talking about the president's
forward is about judges my afterwards
catches up what's happened during the
Trump administration on judges because
my memoir came out three years ago
before the president was elected what
we've done here the president I together
with his paper back that you've shown on
the screen is to talk about how the
judge project came about how it went
forward if you will recall Sean the most
important decision I've made in my
entire political career was not to fill
the Supreme Court vacancy when Justice
Scalia passed away that was the
beginning and now we've got a
exclamation point here after three years
that we thought the public would be
interested in reading about and that's
why the president I collaborated on this
paper back so I was shocked at the
former President Obama love so many
vacancies and didn't try to fill those
positions I'll say why I'll tell you why
I was in charge of the of what we did
the last two years of the Obama
administration was a good life well
congratulations on the book will be
watching obviously very closely in the
Senate do you see any possible
defections I doubt it I doubt it there's
zero chance the president obviously
would be removed from office and I'm
hoping we'll have no defections at all
all right senator Mitch McConnell thank
you for being with us